space travel it's one of humanity's most
truly miraculous achievements building
the technology to defy gravity and
journey into the stars above a place our
ancestors could only dream of going
throughout history humans have found
gods and heroes in the constellations
and today when we look up into the sky
we have the privilege of knowing that
flesh and blood mortals live up there
alongside them it's humbling
inspirational and a downright awesome
thing but of course there's always going
to be naysayers people who just want to
reign on our interstellar parade and
nobody fits this bill harder than people
affected by an anomalous phenomenon
classified by the scp foundation as
scp-2001
the space oddity and before you ask no
the late david bowie is not and never
has been an scp to truly understand this
anomaly we need to take a look at three
different people who are affected by it
to varying degrees let's start with your
friend kevin even if you don't have a
friend called kevin you definitely have
at least a casual acquaintance just like
him kevin is a very confident man with
plenty of ill-informed opinions he'd be
more than happy to argue about until the
heat death of the universe he's the kind
of guy who can turn a discussion about
your favorite movie into world war 3 but
you never knew until recently that he
held such strong opinions on space
travel one day you were discussing the
latest rocket launch with a mutual
friend of yours while kevin just
happened to be in earshot the second you
start talking about how exciting it'll
be to one day put a person on mars he
swaggers over face twisted into a
grimace you're already preparing for him
to say something cringe-inducing and
kevin being kevin he doesn't disappoint
ah don't tell me you two dweebs are
talking about space travel what a stupid
waste of money you guys know there's
nothing but rocks up there right aliens
don't exist it's all just another excuse
for dumb scientists to waste my tax
dollars on playing with their stupid
toys how about you two talk about
something that really matters you may be
thinking kevin is just a jerk and he
definitely is but he's also a victim a
victim of scp-2001
you see 2001 is described as an
anomalous series of neural oscillations
that occur during three of the four
stages of sleep namely nrem or non-rapid
eye movement sleep during one of these
three stages the amygdala a part of the
brain also known as the lizard brain
enters a heightened state of activity
for 10 to 15 minutes once the process
has started even waking up the affected
individual will do nothing to stop the
actual infection there are no traits
that predispose people to a cp 2001
infection it appears to infect people in
equal measures regardless of age gender
and race spectrographic analysis on the
afflicted has shown that the condition
may not be intraneural meaning
originating within the brain and may
actually be the product of an outside
influence the invariable effect of
scp-2001 is the infected developing
negative feelings towards the concept of
space travel and increasing gradations
of severity depending on which stage of
nrem sleep the anomaly began to take
effect a real concern to the foundation
is that scp-2001 seems to be manifesting
with increasing frequency in astronomers
astronauts and individuals who otherwise
deal with space the scp-2001 case
manifests in three different varieties
gamma beta and alpha each variety has
its own unique traits and idiosyncrasies
we've encountered a gamma type already
your dear friend kevin this is the most
mild type of scp-2001 infection and also
the most common affecting at least one
percent of the global population it
occurs for those who were infected
during the second stage of nrem sleep
people with gamma type scp-2001
infection will for the most part seem
like their normal selves save for a
disparaging attitude towards the concept
of space travel whenever it's brought up
they'll likely complain and change the
subject immediately but it won't affect
their behavior too much overall the same
cannot be said for people with beta type
scp-2001 infection meet riley you've
never spoken to riley before but she's a
young woman who likes to hang out at
your local cafe often seen frantically
typing on her laptop you assume she's
writing a screenplay or a novel but in
fact she's posting simultaneously on
multiple conspiracy forums among her
favorite theories are that the earth is
flat space is a hologram and the moon
landing was faked by stanley kubrick
director of such films as the shining
and appropriately 2001 a space odyssey
you made the heinous mistake of going to
your local cafe at the same time as
riley one morning while wearing a nasa
baseball cap an error that you would
come to regret deeply you bought a latte
and decided to sit down for a moment
just the briefest little rest but that
was all the time riley needed her eyes
seemed to burn with hatred you asked if
there was anything you could do to help
her and she responded you're just buying
into some propaganda do you have any
idea what nasa really stands for it's
never a straight answer all their
supposed achievements the moon landing
the iss dehydrated astronaut food it's
all a big sham nasa is just some slush
fund for corrupt government officials no
human has ever been able to survive in
space it's too dangerous anyone sent up
there will die immediately no exceptions
and even if they did it would be
pointless space is just a dark infinite
void that goes on forever it's just a
big pile of dangerous lies oh my
goodness feeling awkward you decide to
just get up and leave that's when riley
grabs your nasa cap right off your head
and throws it in the trash that's fine
you don't intend on going back for it
you just keep walking trying your best
to move calmly out the door wise
decision because riley is actually a
beta type scp-2001
infectee as you can probably tell beta
cases are a lot more severe than gamma
cases and people infected with them seem
to come off as deranged conspiracy
theorists with a rabid hatred of all
space travel they'll form elaborate
fantasies about the falsification of
space travel and will often decry it as
too pointless or dangerous to ever be
undertaken but of course the danger of
beta types pale in comparison to alpha
types these are people infected by
scp-2001 during rem sleep the stage of
sleep typically associated with dreaming
as a result its effects on the mind are
far more dangerous and profound take for
instance the tragic case of scp
foundation junior researcher martinez he
was one of the many operatives stationed
at foundation outpost 12 a complex that
works in coordination with nasa to
launch both manned and unmanned missions
into space on behalf of the foundation's
interests it's a valuable asset to the
foundation in investigating and
combating space-based anomalies martinez
who had previously spent time working
with
scp-2001-infected d-classes was part of
ground control something that would
prove to be a literally fatal oversight
on the part of the foundation during the
early stages of takeoff for a man craft
martinez seemed to become extremely
agitated over time this agitation
steadily increased and eventually became
a full-on breakdown as the rocket
ascended he pulled out some kind of
strange anomalous control device and
began disrupting the operations of the
rocket martinez was shot dead by guards
as a defensive measure but it was
already too late the craft exploded and
everyone on board was tragically killed
later investigation into the incident
found a crucial piece of evidence tying
junior researcher martinez to scp-2001
they discovered a journal entry he'd
written shortly before his breakdown
which seemed to have been written in a
completely different style to prior
entries implying that some kind of
massive psychological shift had occurred
the following is the contents of that
journal entry i wish to state first that
my mind and body are perfectly sound i
am prepared to submit myself to any and
all tests to prove that i am clean i
have the answer to
scp-2001 just yesterday during an
interview with an alpha infected d-class
i was asked a question that stopped my
mind for a minute the woman i was
interviewing asked me if i knew the
foundation was right i said no i wasn't
sure then she asked me what if we were
right i could only assume that by we she
meant 2001 carriers i said nothing for a
while and then she spoke she told me of
a dream she'd had a while ago she said
that something talked to her told her
about how dangerous outer space was it
showed her the beast that roamed the
void between stars about the fractal
beings that absorbed the very fabric of
reality about the expunged that was
keeping in that god-forsaken door and
she was scared she told me at the end of
the dream as she woke up it told her
what it was it's all of space
space fears us we're living breathing
life forms and space loves us and
cherishes us she asked me if i had any
idea what the chances of intelligent
life forming on another planet are then
she told me a number that took a minute
and a half to recite by this point i
couldn't speak i started thinking about
the demographics of infection about the
symptoms about more expunged data here
and suddenly it all made sense some of
the things she said stuck in my brain
and they all added up to the same thing
that we are in grave danger if we go out
there we can't go out there we can't
there's a reason behind scp-2001
and it's nowhere near as terrifying as
all my colleagues think space wants to
protect us there are things out there
that would wipe humanity clean off of
this plane of existence and we are too
precious to our mother to our host to
the universe we live in for her to allow
that to happen what i am going to do
tomorrow is not the result of infection
it is not the result of madness it is
not a result of anything other than
purest knowledge you see i found out the
truth and it's more beautiful than i
could have ever dreamed given what
martinez would later go on to do it's
clear that he wasn't in a sound a state
of mind as he thought as you probably
already gathered people suffering from
alpha-type scp-2001 infection will do
anything they can to actively prevent or
sabotage attempts at space travel this
is a minor concern when it comes to
civilians but when it infects people who
actually work in these fields like
junior researcher martinez it can have
devastating results but this isn't where
this story ends while it's currently
extremely classified there is actually a
fourth category of scp-2000 infection
discovered in the wake of martinez's
death a key element of the alpha strain
is that it cannot cause people to
perform acts that they would find
immoral such as murdering the entire
crew of a man's shuttle with a crash
however the fourth category known as
alpha prime does away with any moral
compunctions whatsoever people infected
with this virus will prevent space
travel by any means necessary and unlike
other scp 2001 infections you aren't
compromised in your sleep this time the
vector for infection is simply talking
to someone infected with the regular
alpha strain and hearing a few key
trigger phrases that's how junior
researcher martinez caught it from
d-classes he was working with what are
these key phrases we still don't know
but if you find that you suddenly have
much stronger opinions about space
travel than you've ever had before try
to keep them to yourself now check out
scp-096 look at the picture of the shy
guy in space
scp-096 questions and theories and
scp-5000-y the full compilation for more
fascinating foundation facts